inflections inflections are the upward
down of our communication someone
without inflection would be considered
monotone and they speak like this they
drone on and on and on and it doesn't
matter how exciting the particular
section is it just stays the same
inflection is critically responsible for
how emotionally attached we are to what
we're saying if people cannot feel your
passion your commitment your emotion
behind your pitch they're not going to
get excited they're not going to have a
connection about your pitch so make sure
that you stay out of the rut of talking
in one straight line the whole time you
want to be thinking about what emotions
you're trying to evoke one emotion might
be authority for an authoritative sound
do you want to be doing a downward
inflection another one might want to be
curiosity and Wonder an upward
inflection and another one might want to
be complete inspiration and motivation
this could then be a balance of both a
downward inflection of confidence and an
upward inflection of motivating others
to follow your lead